i'm david m i'm a senior security
researcher with the global research and
analysis team at Kaspersky Lab some
Russian hackers have created a website
and the website contains footage of
thousands of devices out there on the
Internet including CCTV cameras webcams
and baby monitors they can use software
vulnerabilities and loopholes in the
code in order to hack into a device like
this if it has an internet connection
but on the other hand it's also true
that many devices like this come with a
default password which the manufacturer
has set so here's what you can do to
protect webcams CCTV cameras and any
other Internet connected device change
the default username and password on
webcams baby monitors and any other
device that's going to be connected to
the Internet check if there are any
security updates for your router the new
router is the front door into your house
in electronic terms if the software is
out of date and attackers are able to
find loopholes or flaws in the software
they can use that to force their way in
many computers laptops tablets and
smartphones also come with webcams built
in so it's really important that you
install internet security software on
them don't forget that low-tech
solutions can help you here too there's
no reason why you can't put some tape
over the webcam or if you're doing
anything sensitive of the device in the
drawing